pop
[Musique]
oh
m
[Musique]
enfin fabien quoi je relis tout cela si
j'ai un peu de temps je me partir à un
peu de balzac
j'ai un max de lecture en retard et
cours à bienne la bibliothèque nationale
bn ne pouvait pas connaître non orientés
comme ça je me demande comment vous
allez peut-être comme ça avec vos
prothèse dans les oreilles nous pourquoi
on est passé on le laisse sonner le
téléphone
fini le téléphone finis les petits
dessins les gros et moyens fini rideau
on part en vacances d'accord alors on y
va alors c'est le grand départ
et qui c'est qui seraient contents
partir aussi en vacances un départ alors
on va pas rester ici il ya plus de
personnes
tu crois que les agressions
mais ensuite vous payez vous disent que
chacun est trop grand et patati et
patata attaque imaginaire mais toujours
devant nous on vend verdaich et on se
baigne abadan vacances monsieur chalette
et bonnes vacances
au revoir au revoir
[Musique]
des gestes s'acheter une camionnette
moussy un lieu 1
[Musique]
google s'est déroulé dans bug on a
rendez vous là bernard et nous à bernard
moretti toujours le paradis avec ses
ex-femmes ses voisins ses enfants était
là oui quoi bon bah bah voyons pas par
la répression s'est passé n'est pas
oublié mon chèque
ah non non voilà
ce manque et on parle aussi peux pas
faut pas qu'on les fasse attendre
surtout si on prend les petits troquets
j'aimerais bien qu'ils se couchent pas
trop tard je vais passer les vacances
écoutez pas passer les balles parce
qu'il faut puis dorment mieux à sa
monnaie tout à propos chat ils ont des
caillettes de parts de vacances
j'aimerais bien que tu surveilles je
compte sur toi atcha oui on occuperait
divin
aussi faut plus tarder maintenant toi je
passerai de prendre le 8 où on a trente
sept jours et demi chacun prêchait
on y va bon alors mais les membres du
relais par semaine ces moments à contrer
tout tout je compte sur vous
bon marché
[Musique]
enfin les radios
on parle de nous avec des toits en fin
[Musique]
et ça va passer numéro title ginai de
grâce à la tempête et clermont 6 et la
sueur de papa c'est forcément notre
temps plus que ça
[Musique]
oui
mais ce sont justement bah ouais on est
sur la route 1 justement vain de se
barrer
je comprends la personne du nom bon ok
ça lui
c'est grand c'est quoi pascal arrêtons
de juger est là qu'on va la fois à paris
pour tourner à vis à vis et plein de
vacheries ça fait mal non ça swingue de
ma mère mon père s'empêche de gonfler
heureusement qu'il avait la bouche
fermée parce que louis nature la bouche
ouverte par action dia de rentrer dans
la bouche elle s'affole parce qu'elle
croit qu'il fait nuit alors pas elle
pique alors a pas ça gonfle gonflement
de gauche alors toi tu convaincu au
super gonflé et tout et tout tu meurs
pareil pour autant sortir 6 400 g
trouvant la gorge
[Musique]
vous venez avec moi cette question voici
votre affaire non écrite de la radio
festivini d'attentât et blanches et tu
pouvais pas à m'appeler et ce matin
maison j'ai essayé le dock est déjà
parti c'était toi de téléphone tout à
fait répondu bah si on avait répondu on
se répond à des prix bas et ma jambe
qu'est ce qu'il ya alors elle a foncé
sur téléphone elle a appelé la radio
elle leur a fait une grande tirade
féministe on féminise bonheur joie dit
la stricte vérité
j'aurais dit je suis carte grâce mon
mari cartographes nous avons fait un
miti cartographe l enfant qu après qu on
verra plus tard dans sa vie alors a dit
il ya que vous pour nous tirer
d'affaires ah oui c'est vrai je leur ai
dit on est tous les deux cartes
graphiques nous propose un boulot génial
pour le gabon seulement voilà il ya un
petit ennui il faut partir immédiatement
et on est en pleines vacances
et qu'est ce qu'on fait avec le petit
alors quand on est une femme cartographe
qu'on est l'enfant ont peuplé de
cartographes et qu'est-ce qu'ils ont
répondu ah je leur ai pas laissé le
temps de répondre je leur ai dit de
passer le message i media luz ont menacé
rue ou nas ou faut pas charrier j'aurais
dit que tu étais le seul à pouvoir me
tirer d'affaires est avec toi c'est elle
seule qui pouvait garder manuel pendant
notre séjour au gabon et et elle seule
notre petit manuel
c'est un contrat de deux mois on
remplace de cartographes
enfin bref ils peuvent pas partir on
peut vivre sans faire de cartes on
dérange tout le monde avec cette
histoire
[Musique]
c'est que c'est pas simple on a loué une
maison dans l'ardèche avec charles mais
je la connais pas mon la baraque au
maire charles gens qui nous attends tu
te rends compte de la comptabilité un
petit poème pareil j'ai même pas celle
de la place l'humain nous vient nous en
pointe de la torche veiller que toi sa
maman est partie la mienne aussi
ya que toi allons justement il n'y a pas
que moi je veux dire il ya tout le monde
ya charles charles qui nous attend
fayard ya tout le monde ya sa de ses
enfants les miens l'inconnu là-bas en
ardèche mais bon toute façon c'est moi
qui m'en occuperai et puis tant leurs
dents vie moi oulémas nous
man your man ou man ou woman ou tu veux
tu veux bien dit tu veux bien partir
avec l'oncle bernard tu veux bien tu
veux bien non
[Musique]
ils ont soit mairie un accident
au moins si papa
[Musique]
mais ça va je crois que c'est leur
voiture non létale a battu richard
jours
des trésors depuis la semaine dernière
est un qui marche tous dessus et
l'entrée bête c'est mon petit neveu
manou à laure manaudou dit pas bonjour
mon vieux copain ça
t'inquiète pas ses nationaux mais à part
ça il est extra ça va pas ça va l'homme
était vachement gonflé vachement je suis
dans ce bled de bourgogne depuis des
heures et des heures atelier t comme
sera un ça va
et en fait ce soir en ardèche ça va mais
je me suis finalement 802 comptable j'ai
tout imaginer tous y compris l'accident
éruption volcanique dans le mauvais
pourquoi pas c'est vachement sûrement
ces trucs là mais j'ai tout imaginer
tout le charme tout ça c'est la faute à
manou si si qui ment alors alors j'ai
pensé qu'on pourrait dormir ici je me
suis rangé avec le patron bravo vieux
charles à ta place j'en avais fait
autant aller
[Musique]
nous y voici donc je récapitule et or
devront là nous avons un radis beurre là
un saucisson à la trépigner là une
crudité sauce labiche là un poireau à la
retourner là nous avons 1 9 à l'as saint
pétersbourg ont hélas une cochonnailles
vont terminer je prends associant à
trépigner à la place de moyens du bord
oui mais plutôt pour moi la retourner je
préfèrerais un à face au slavia
mais c'est à dire c'est la crudité qui
est à la sauce labiche l'oeuf et à saint
pétersbourg quoi je voudrais un
saucisson être puni à la place de ma
cochonnailles montagneuses et moi avec
mon nom à saint-pétersbourg un machin à
trépigner or fait chaud fois je
reprendrai mon ras du montant atteint je
prendrais du truc douchette répit ne
fera de radis bon alors comme plat
principal qu'est ce que c'est au moins
la duc de guise qui accusait à remercier
voit le pâté d'écouté alterhéros d'el
madher c'est quoi c'est bon les
écrevisses au plafonnier et l'afrique
assez rigolo de ce détective pour tout
le monde achetait crit citt avec un
supplément d'accord ça voilà alors tout
le monde est d'accord
oui bon d'accord elle et toi pour tâche
de parrot fait moi je me bats ouf la kul
m
bon ben alors super malin moi il faut
que je vise
on lit pas la nuit on résiste quand on
veut logiquement si tu lis maintenant ça
veut dire que pendant toute l'année et a
glané deux premiers on verra quand ils
seront en terminale superman au revoir
on est dommage qu'avec les bonnes femmes
ont toujours un mec avec de bonne foi
mois avec trois règles elle va pas c'est
une danseuse je crois alors moi ça se
passe je t'aimerai dortoir vous êtes
bien là comme disent les suisses je suis
déçu en bien par ce cheval noir et
pourquoi ça s'appelle pas jamais les
juments noir les hôtels un ballet de
faire le don mais parce que demain matin
des classiques le bonheur à nîmes à
grande échelle au web
non mais à papa
c'est quoi ce truc mais nous savons à
qui n'a pu l'éviter alors l'éléphant
jour ni le mandat l'hippopotame gaston
l'instant c'est ça il s'appelait gaston
alors ils demandent à quelle heure du
conte sous café alors l'hippopotame
rétorque aussitôt et bain dès que les
dés que les cafés des forêts ouvre et
dès que les moments buffle on va porter
le relais et dès que nous endormir
je vais prendre garde à cherry a du
pointon honda oui il y en avoir dans mon
bar et que vous savez favori wen est
vraiment mignon ça prend pas trop de
temps en temps envie d'avoir un enfant
non mais moi je suis divorcée mois moi
aussi je suis divorcée a marre qu'on
peut très bien faire un monde sans
s'être marié monde est plein de femmes
subi ouais c'est vrai il ya plein de
femmes c'est plein de femmes mais moi je
rencontre jamais c'est ce que tu fais tu
te fabrique une pancarte est écrit
dessus cherche femme tu sais comme dans
l'es17 son pays et tu parles comme ça un
peu partout avec soi dans le monde arabe
j'aurais l'air fab apporte certes c'est
pas vrai que je rencontre jamais de
femmes genre en compte mais ça marche
jamais je dois pas faire ce qu'il faut
les lire assez je sais pas et admettons
je dégote une merveilleuse créature avec
qui ça marchait mal tu fais un enfant
est basse et ça fait un beau jour elle
divorce et je me retrouve tout seul
séparé file avance j'aime pas à dormir
avec tous ces trucs là match doha la
danoise plein ça rien autrement je dors
pas ok mais moi je tends pas le bâloise
moi tu as tort voilà peut-être moi je
vous marier
ça m'étonne pas qu'ils bonne photo
largue
si tu fais tous cherchent actuellement
au cul ça c'est pas gentil alors ça
c'est vraiment pas gentil de dire ça ne
va pas te la tension a régné
[Musique]
sa femme on tue pas nous avoir fait le
tour ou plutôt qui va pas dire quand
même intéressé
je peux faire
alors ça continue
[Musique]
la première technique trop à droite et
après moi je te suis
[Musique]
mais pas maintenant
avec monsieur la dent oui on le suit
jusqu'à la maison pour la louer ils nous
montrent le ch n'a pas compris oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
spéciaux ni comment ça paraît vraiment
bien tu trouves pingeot et du vent on
dirait non du jour
hu et pour dénier monsieur site web moi
je voudrais new pas pour tous yalla rek
oui et la mer et vous m'avez certains la
mer ici croit nuit alors mme hanoune ça
plaît pas julien sur la mi mai n'a pas
séduit
on est trop de marge d'un pneumatique et
les sacs de couchage idéal pour cela la
douche et wc sont pas à part mais c'est
comme à paris les enfants en
l'occurrence hd grand lit oui oui moi je
trouve à thiais mieux bernard ah bon ah
ben tu penses que ce que je devrais bien
l'aspect urbain et comme la nuit les
courants d'air de gérants
mais tu peux la posture non non non
l'autre va très bien va falloir
s'organiser c'est le gym est d'abord
faut déménager tout ça plus qu'à la
camionnette avait mon vieux et mac os
c'est pratique ça tu t'occupes du de ma
fille tu maladie a différé sont devant
moi dit papa je m'en fais pas l'athlète
web qu'est ce qui va relancer rien juste
un peu sa nature
[Applaudissements]
et attention plongeant assez pas
l'atlantique wall eva joly ça va ça
allait champions allô allô
ah non mais tu vas voir
[Applaudissements]
et bien la manouba chapeau
institutionnels voilà ta faire un bond
de doha
s'éclate à mr ouai aussi il n'ya pas de
toi
mais sera un peu de place sur ta
l'alcool aucune
j'ai fini papa tu laly est clairement
moins chère maman comment ça va comme on
est menotté ça va moi je vais bien
là on est sur la plage j'ai mon mac bon
masque et mes palmes et le tube on a
fait chavirer charles est pas sa part
c'est moi qui raconte qu'on a fait
chavirer challes c'est pas marrant c'est
écrit ce que j'écris moi tu n'as carrier
j'ai vu un poisson argenté est
mirobolant
je plonge duo du gros rochers qui tombe
à pic
la nuit on est piqué par des bêtes qu'on
voit qu'on ne voit pas je te fais me
baiser ma maman on mange un machin qui
s'appelle qui s'appelle branche d'ad
c'est la charte et qui lança avants ont
su barbe un peu quand charles et papa
feu la sieste font la sieste on fait la
vaisselle avec le magnétophone
ça va être dur sein avec le magnétophone
de julienne on se poile un max et va
assez bien
en vain j'envoie
[Musique]
et
oui
le
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
d
par quoi tu as un coup de déprime
depuis qu'on est ici sa palette à fait
par nous tous un peu nos vieux sort j'en
sais rien moi pour faire des rencontres
des gens nouveaux
une femme peut-être temps va passer pour
les finances sont tous ici
voiture et puis j'ai réfléchi je trouve
plus de sel bien passé une femme ne st
pas en vacances comtois tu vois je suis
sûr qu'à quelques pas qu'elles attendent
mais où magicien capable de me trouver
une compagne ouais on en vient d'ouvrir
un chemin pavé stocker
[Musique]
jeune et bien bon soir
et
[Musique]
là
d'habitude à halle et bonsoir bonsoir je
vais dire
je veux dire je suis quand même content
pour passer les vacances ensemble même
si j'ai l'air triste
[Musique]
moi tout seul avec mes mots
rome
[Musique]
à
ben je vais voir si l'on arrêtait la
lumière c'est sacripant
[Musique]
il a fait tout est noir oui vous vous
êtes arrêté de parler quand je suis
entré nous oui vous l'une au mirail
mais qu'est ce que vous avez à me
regarder comme ça
voyez la photo est les bons soirs le
mystérieux
toutefois la charger n'oubliez pas
d'éteindre j'ai une idée géniale
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pas désunie qu'hier 10h06 réveil -
chirac je racontais toutes les histoires
que je connaissais peu plus fourni 19h53
une italie ou quoi bonsoir dit papa tu
l'emportés tombola on peut la wii
polaroid je les prie pour quoi que tu
veux bien le prêter pour effet pour
faire une surprise surprise
non
[Musique]
en vérité tout
passage du public
m
[Musique]
le
mauvaise montrera de bagdad en couleurs
avec mes copains ses mains et c'est moi
qui fonctionne avec vous qui ferez avec
moi que pour la lessive et vous les
gagnants perdants une minute plus tard
et il a tout fait pour la prépa nourrit
pas forcément tu commences hockey
[Applaudissements]
bonjour les poussins sa mort et une
enquête a les photos pour le bahut
booster les bacs
oui mais on fait ça pour la rentrée vous
voulez bien répond ça dépend des
questions on s'est pas compliqué
compliqué posait toujours je verrais
bien démarrer enfin et les hommes les
autres
recommençons désolé mr quoi parce que
dire que je suis est marié non pour la
fée cette photo paulin
journal voilà aujourd'hui damidot vous
êtes mariés vous n'êtes pas divorcer ou
à l'instance pour les choses comme ça
c'est pareil non
bon bah leur temps par jour vous êtes
mariés non mais les enfants et
littéraire et vous avez vu nous
m
[Musique]
ce n'est pas la fin du gala projet
environs de l'essence a fini
[Musique]
je
le
[Musique]
m
qu'ils me voient comme celui là dans
l'air un peu cruche
oui cela l'a un peu de mousse la wii si
je comprends pas pourquoi vous
photographiez duc ces dames
on l'a fait pour le voilà voilà
d'abord testé chars mais l'on devrait
pas envoyé il n'a pas une équipe pas
plus qu'une autre
et moi alors toi après les grosses
chaleurs petit tout petit ce qu'elle est
petite
c'est un homme louche très louche
si l'on sait pas il apparaît peu est
trop grand même s'il est à 6
mais pourquoi vous voulez absolument
avoir mon avis sur toutes ces dames mais
nous devons rien d'avoir des photos
c'est tout les photos pour la presse
pour notre concours
c'est sûrement parce que tu es très très
difficile et que tu as nancy c'est
l'aele et ouais et comment dire
elle est oui
elle me rappelle une fille de l'école
elle et ouais moi une fille de l'école
vraiment elle est aussi votre couchez
vous allez en bas et ben moi je vais te
coucher parce que c'est l'heure de se
coucher les enfants sortis ils sont aux
lignes voilà sans galipettes moyenne et
non et puis ce soir tu vas voir une
couche moi ce que tu m'as fait défaut
papa tu as vu la femme de ma vie mais
comment ça commence à vous avez tout à
une fin pour charles ben oui c'était
bidon le concours on a photographié
toutes fines est là pour ça et on essaie
maintenant qu'elle vivait comme à l'ailé
belgique
c'est moi qui ai eu l'idée du polar vous
avez fait sa ba oui tous vous auriez pu
leur demander leurs amis quand même ça
ça lui chante peut-être à deux dans le
fichier des éventuels 6 ans et charles
moi je dois dire que je suis fier de
leur truc une agence matrimoniale
connected with it e pour faire plaisir à
charge et lingettes marié est trop loin
tiens mais je pense à une chose on a pas
l adresse du sida et en plus il est même
pas efficace évidemment vous amuser plus
à faire des trucs pareils
voilà voyez donc plus on fait range nous
non non non pas du tout pourquoi tu nous
dérangerait non on est en vacances plus
ensemble tous ensemble on s'amuse comme
des fous et et tu ne me dérange pas du
tout voilà un manuel
fraport pourquoi tu ne dérangerait wars
ou quoi on n'a rien à cacher qu est-ce
qu on cachera ça c'est le demande
bon bon bon admettons
en tout cas quand je chanterai tout le
monde s'est tu on s'est tu en as tu
rigoles pour qu'on se serait tu un nom
on disait simplement que demain il
faudra se lever de bonne heure pour que
c'est bien de se tromper un peu les
fesses
voilà un peu long
cette garde comme ont plongé à huy fait
gaffe c'est pas compliqué la young heart
à vue j'en ai créé un autre jour j'ai
rien d'optionnel oui même à l'émaillage
s'est loupé toujours tu peux en mettre
un peu dans le dos d'ailleurs il faut
pas louper
impossible battu qui ont un peu d'argent
or combien un peu là une minute pour là
je sais pas ça dépend une ou deux bouts
ce alors tu quittes ton âge tu peut même
mettre un peu de bouteille mais ça c'est
comme tu veux une fois que l'on aille
épiler tu sais par le jaune d'oeuf avec
le blanc oui ben moi je sépare jamais
bien et je pour mlle jaune dans l'évier
non c'est humain écoute ça c'est quand
même pas sorcier de ses parents un jeune
homme de son blanche va casser la
fontaine là que tout va comme ça n'a
plus existé
une fois que tu as séparer les jaunes
d'oeufs avec le blanc qui le verse sur
la pile et et tu prends de l'huile
d'olive l'huile d'olive c'est pas trop
fort ça donne pas trop de vous alors là
alors là je pèse mes mots un sable
l'aïoli avec de l'huile d'arachide c'est
d'un crime d'ailleurs c'est bien connu
que l'huile d'olive c'est excellent pour
la santé
alors tu prends ton il d'une main ta
cuillère en bois de l'autre et tu touil
gratuite ou le jaune du vert 50000 tu
trouves tu te sens lâcher ça monte ça
monte
[Applaudissements]
mais semble mais ça que j'ai déjà vu
quelque part dont tu crois
habib c'est vraiment ça me tente mais
c'est pas seul
[Musique]
samura ça va pas tu le jeu en attaque
je sais vraiment pas comment vous
remercier sans vous c'était drame à
travers ces pages l'histoire caoutchouc
j'ai quand même
non c'était le drame vous avez sauvé
mondory vous avez sauvé notre neveu
enfin m
fâché points de retard à la grèce chaque
fois
[Musique]
qu'ajouter à bâle
mais c'est pas comme au polaroïd a alors
c'est vous le concours
ah oui oui c'est setteuse je n'ai pas la
route bande
c'est bizarre à quel point si dense
[Applaudissements]
oignies allez viens et civils elle nous
a dit qu'elle n'était pas marié mois
nous est racontée en chambre howie dans
son milieu naturel
c'est pas là on a pas besoin d'être
mariée pendant deux ans quand tu regarde
jamais les films à la télé réveille-toi
en tout cas on perd une puce va nous
tirerons jamais lu des trucs n'a pas
volé ma vie d'avant
[Applaudissements]
non
non non c'est chez vous on va bientôt
rentrer nom vient d'arriver quand j'ai
encore une fois comme la meilleure pour
les bienvenus bon dernier plongeon 1,6
ont dîné tous ensemble ce soir
ah oui c'est une bonne idée ça mais
seulement ce soir tu vas pas aller
chercher ta femme aucun incident n'est
plus la femme
enfin jeanne quoi la nappe était enfant
tu vois pas la prendre car ce soir mais
non c'est demain matin on a trente sept
jours et demi du matin c'est le demi va
alors tu es libre comme l'air tu les as
vite
[Musique]
ce cirque
et
[Musique]
bernard
sharp a ni hypocrite a copy nos gars
elle arrive demain à 11 heures
nous sommes
[Musique]
[Rires]
enfantin
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
des lasagnes naturellement des lasagnes
on va pas recevoir cette femme sublime
avec du genre de salade 1
mais mais mais elle va pas trouver ça un
peu lourds peuvent plus que des lasagnes
ah bon ah bon bah puisque c'est comme ça
moi je rends mon tablier
tu t'es bien pas charles avec des
connaissances mais mais mais mais mais
connaissant ccct connaissance est fausse
note bref moi j'en ai marre
non mais on se met en quatre et on se
fait traiter de clown les nommer mais
j'ai parlé des lézards pas de toi
fenêtre mizan et moi c'est la même chose
c'est dur toi alors tu vois non bon ben
je ne t'ai pas de dire ça mais c'est
peut-être parce qu'ils s'en vont dommage
ils sont certainement très bonnes c'est
telle azag paf look du tout
que je rappe combien de fromage pour des
lasagnes mon paul du débarras s'il te
plaît tu es 2 j'ai jamais mangé des
lasagnes aussi bonne jamais tout le
mérite en revient à charles
il devrait ouvrir un restaurant à la
tarte au citron d'amgen tu vois c'est
pas difficile et ça doit être trop
mauvais parce que mon père qui se
termine ce conteur tu vois comme ça en
février avoir allaité mes cousins elles
sont enfin nous on a dû passer pour 2
c'est pas mal aussi maman les enfants tu
vois question tard luminus
mais les crêpes alors tant que tu veux
d'ailleurs quand j'étais petit on
passait des vacances en bretagne est
alors partout sucre aux yeux ou jambon
salade sans point en choix fromage est
ce que raconte qu'il voulait en faire
mais ça c'est plus une crêpe c'est une
pizza au moins les barrages
bonjour à un moment quand on se tape
dessus tout ça au drapeau qui viennent
lr d'excusés 1
alors tenir demain
tiens je te laisse la bête humaine je
les lui vous êtes le bienvenu aussi
jeudi à charles c'est une grande maison
près de toulon juste au dessus de la mer
non moi je reste ici il ya encore un
mois de location
et puis ça nous a séduit est ce que tu
racontes
c'est gentil de m'avoir invité annie
surtout que je l'aide sans mes enfants
et puis mon ami est très simple et y
laisser votre ami comme redouté
[Musique]
car
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
adou 3d n'était ni nouvelle qualité
et j'ai raison j'y ai dit oui absolument
raison deux éclairages promis
amis
me plaît vraiment et moi tu crois que
jeunes demain de jus plaît tu crois bien
sûr tu me plais autrement elle n'aurait
pas réalité non c'est vrai
j'aime bien quand elle sourit
dis moi j'ai bien fait d'accepter je ne
me pose pas mais non tu t'imposes pas
relax relax tout ce qui est plus relax
moi vraiment une belle nuit
une nuit on souhaiterait être romeo et
grimper au balcon de juliette et roméo
et juliette
c'est beau
à
[Musique]
je
vous avez fait les gorges et en russe ou
en famille non mais parfaitement espagne
et voitures
on va les faire ça
[Musique]
renault
à toi patients septembre à la rentrée
quoi
un jour
on joue les bons jours est-ce que vous
avez bonne nuit à tous
bonjour charles
[Musique]
au petit et au gouverneur alors toi
c'est la forme et oui ça pour les
enfants aussi d'ailleurs
rsa lui manille vous connaissez bien sûr
c'est elle qui est venue chercher et
vous
c'est vraiment
[Musique]
si tu savais comme je suis contente
d'aller avec tous à l'avenir
[Musique]
on a le don pour la fin c'est un métier
que l'on a moins femmes comment on
devient pas fan mais papa que dans
l'aisne ma fac où les magrets soir papa
de tous
à
[Musique]
tusa
papou
et c'est faux
mais tant de temps
des arbres
à petit sans nuitée est tracassé mai
mais on partage mon s'aiment bien
ça fait moins apporter chaque un peu de
joie de bonheur
chacun chacune nos valeurs tout
jean à
allah
pas plus
[Musique]
dieu
et
sympa
l'état de papa
les désarment pas
marin
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ok
[Musique]